Це колиска санного спорту України.
Навесні, коли весь сніг розтає,
у цьому місці залишається сніг.
Тут таке місце, як невеличкий холодильничок,
тримає завжди холод.
Взагалі, починав зі стрибків з трампліну,
але оскільки я хлопець важкий, великий,
дідусь каже: «Тут санна траса є,
приходь — спробуєш».
Прийшов на санну трасу — справді, тут таких треба.
В нас такий спорт більш кординаційний.
І для старту потрібна вибухова сила.
Давай, давай!
Гоп, гоп!
Склад дорослої збірної зараз — шість осіб.
У нас база олімпійського резерву.
Діти й батьки бачать,
що можна пробитись на змагання найвищого рівня.
І сюди приходить дуже багато дітей.
Та й вид спорту цікавий — швидкість.
Всі діти люблять швидкість.
Санний спорт почав в Україні розвиватись
на початку 60-х років ХХ століття.
І включений цей вид спорту до програми Олімпійських ігор.
Тоді він почав розвиватися
і в Радянському союзі, і в Україні.
Санний спорт на Кременнечині бере свій початок
ще з 30-х років ХІХ століття.
Коли місто Кременець — це була територія Польщі.
І отут, де знаходяться зараз ліси, була облаштована
земляна траса, довжиною близько 400 метрів.
Тоді санний спорт не був видом спорту.
Скоріше — це все були розваги.
Тут спускалися, коли приїжджали відпочивати
з різних міст і з Волині, і з Польщі.
З певним часом відкрили тут спортивну школу.
І теж силами ентузіастів
вже була побудована траса з дерева.
Її довжина сягала 700 метрів.
Санним спортом починають займатись з 9 років.
У 10 років діти, чи взимку чи влітку,
освоюють свої навики їзди і володінням саньми.
Оце — перший захід.
Це ви вже піднялися на місце старту.
Тут дистанція стоїть уже 600 метрів.
Тут стартують хлопці і дівчата віком від 15 до 17 років.
Це вже трішки інші швидкості.
Два регіони залишилося:
Львівська область — саме Львів,
і Кременець, Тернопільська область,
де залишився санний спорт.
Єдине, що тут тримає ту трасу —
є ті міжнародні змагання.
У кращі часи приїжджали 14-15 країн-учасниць.
Такі були популярні змагання.
І просто підтримують, бруси міняють.
Самі ці опори — шпангоути,
вони теж вже прогнивають де-не-де.
В загальній кількості, якщо не помиляюся,
у нас є 170 чи 180 активних санкарів на сьогодні.
Там стартують юніори. От зараз побачите.
Учасники змагань.
А далі йдуть дистанції 800 і 1000 метрів.
У навчально-тренувальному процесі спортсмени використовують.
А для змагань, щоб знов підняти
дорослих спортсменів вище,
необхідно 50% брусу змінити,
бо він вже втратив свою якість.
А безпека спортсменів передовсім!
Ця траса вже 15 років експлуатується.
Тут проводяться взимку,
якщо зима дозволяє, зимові чемпіонати.
Влітку — це змагання на роликах.
Тут потрібно кординацію.
Крім кординації, ще потрібно мати фізичні навики,
бо ці сани спортсмени носять [на собі].
Тут нема підйомників, як закордоном.
І не возять машиною.
Це заключна частина.
Там проїжджають бетонку, от є будиночок —
там стоять фінішні датчики.
Іде фіксація часу.
Там сидить і працює суддівська колегія.
Фіксація результату.
Тут не тільки санний спорт, тут можна зараз розвивати,
досить популярний в міжнародній федерації,
санний спорт на натуральних трасах.
Тут можна гірський туризм розвивати.